[Music]
so george
the producer james just handed us an
article
it's juicy it's a juicy one
well okay
this pisses me off
all right because
the um
consumer financial protection bureau
brought to you by elizabeth warren
that's where it came from
um was put in place to protect the
consumer
they were put in charge of a piece of
legislation that's been in place for 30
or 40 years
called the federal fair debt collection
practices act
there's federal law that dictates how
collectors have to behave
or they're in violation of federal law
when they're trying to collect from you
the consumer financial protection bureau
is in charge of the federal debt fair
debt collection practices act
regulations and uh fines and you know
you know basically protecting the
consumer
so what did they do
under this administration
decided to
help out the collectors
instead of the consumer
so they just
new rules approved by the consumer
financial protection bureau
that took effect this is from npr that
took effect on tuesday dictate how
collection agencies can email or text
people as well as message them on social
media
to collect unpaid debts so now they can
hassle you on twitter
your facebook account
text you and email you
what part of protection
at the bureau did they not get they just
unleash the hounds on the consumer
financial protection
bureau you need to read the title of the
place you work
good god i thought it was bad enough
when my mom joined facebook
and now the collectors are on there too
the whole gang
you can't stop everyone's watching you
george you know a way to fix this is
don't be on facebook
good luck well it's easier now
everyone's going you know they're on
instagram
you have to have something like i got
where i pay people to do this stuff
because i can't stand it but this is
what's crazy it says they can attempt to
join your network by sending you a
friend request and they must give you
the option to opt out of being contacted
online and any messages they send do
have to be private so they're not going
to go posting on your public page dave
don't worry
yeah that would be a violation of
privacy act a whole other act
the rules are really disappointing and
concerning in a number of ways says
april new hoff a staff attorney for the
national consumer law center hello april
that's an
understatement uh yeah disappointing no
this is just ridiculous this is what we
in the south call we just let the fox in
the hen house that's a good saying i
like that one
here's what's crazy chomp chomp we're
going to see so much spam come out of
this it says allowing debt collectors to
email text and use social media to
contact consumers also gives criminals a
new avenue to try to swindle people out
of their money a practice kanuhov
expects to increase in the future i get
a bunch of crap on my apple phone
updates
that i don't want
and they force it on me and i have to go
in and turn it off or turn it on and so
that people aren't watching me and all
this other bull crap all these things
they do with this technology i'm getting
just paranoid but they're gonna have to
put a thing on the apple phone
oh yeah block collector text
select
on or off
and that maybe you know there you go
that'll work
so um i did just somebody just showed me
them i'm so technology stu you're gonna
look at me because you know i'm stupid
but um
yeah you can turn off uh not the phone
doesn't ring if it's an unrecognized
numbers because the 73 000 calls i get a
year on my uh warranty for my car that i
need to buy which is hilarious you're
calling dave ramsey's phone i mean come
on
but um
yeah i mean all those are blocked now
and so automatically they don't it
doesn't ring my phone so i can we're
going to have that selected for
collectors apple's gonna have to protect
us because the protection bureau won't
protect us oh boy and you know the weird
thing about sliding into the dms here on
on your instagram account if the only
people sliding into the dms are the
collectors that's a sad life we got to
pay off this debt get rid of it leave
them on red you can't ghost these people
they're going to be after you
that sums it up